many prominent sociologists over the
past 200 years or so have expected that
religion will slowly wither away that it
would retreat before the forces of
modernization before the increased
knowledge as well as greater
technological prowess as it turns out
these predictions about the demise of
religion have proven not to be correct
religion is continuing to be a vital
force there is a process of D
secularization under way rather than
expected process of secularization and
what we are facing today is the
condition that we have to think about
multiple ways many ways to modernize and
not just one modernization can be
associated with secularization but
modernization processes can go on very
cleanly hand-in-hand with strong and
robust embrace of religion we will be
studying various cases in which we can
comparatively look at various countries
to see these processes of secularization
modernization and D secularization at
play obviously some of the European
societies are prime examples of
modernization and secularization going
hand-in-hand United States on the other
hand is exactly the opposite case where
religion remains to be vital force even
though the processes of modernization
continue to go on robustly in order to
help us in discussion of these topics we
will invite Yale sociologist Phil Gorski
who specializes precisely in comparative
work on secularization in the United
States and in Europe